conduire une voiture électrique sur la
glace est-ce que c'est possible je vous
confirme que oui c'est fort qui m'a
invité ici à venir piloter une Ford
Mustang maki GT sur un circuit de glace
je suis pas un pilote et je peux vous
assurer que la sensation sont
complètement dingues alors on a essayé
différents modes de conduite et surtout
on est venu déconnecter le SP on a coupé
toute l'électronique il y a un truc qui
est génial c'est qu'on retrouve toutes
les sensations d'une voiture hyper
burness ça envoie du bois c'est l'esprit
de Ford c'est l'esprit de Mustang alors
vous connaissez l'idée de la Ford
Mustang les grands espaces les libertés
la marque américaine bref on fait
plaisir et ce qui est génial c'est que
pour voir qu'on a une voiture électrique
on va se dire est-ce qu'on va retrouver
la sensation de pilotage c'est
complètement dingue Sacha ça part d'un
côté la voiture est très joueuse ça
vient casser les préjugés sur les
voitures électriques qui seraient des
voitures où on se fera un petit peu
chiant en terme de sensation mais je
peux vous assurer qu'avec cette Ford
Mustang maki GT ici c'est envoyé du bois
je me suis vraiment marrer donc si vous
avez l'occasion de vous dire les essayer
testez-les d'ailleurs deux questions
première est-ce que vous avez déjà
essayé de piloter une voiture sur un
circuit de glace et puis deuxième
question est-ce que vous avez déjà
essayé une voiture électrique et
peut-être même d'ailleurs si un circuit
de glace dites-le-moi dans les
commentaires